time to begin for us so good morning and
welcome everyone thanks you for thank
you for coming to this talk my name is
adam furmanek and today we are going to
talk a little about async very hot topic
recently like for the last decade in
c-sharp obviously and but today what we
are going to do is we will see it from a
different angle we will see whether
async in c-sharp was implemented in the
right way whether the way it was
implemented allowed us to actually gain
the most of the performance and all the
benefits we could get and if there are
any drawbacks to the implementation we
have in c sharp especially in the light
of the project loom in java which was
released quite recently and which turned
the table significantly so this is what
we are going to do for the next hour we
will discuss how async is implemented
what the pros and cons are and how to
re-implement it using different approach
namely fibers as you can see we'll learn
what fibers are how they can be used in
windows
and whether it's possible to get some
other benefits from this implementation
before we move on couple what about me
i'm a software engineer for over a
decade now i written also two technical
books one about dotnet one about applied
maths uh especially integer linear
programming and how it can be used in
programming i'm also an author of uh of
random it utensils blog at
blog.adamformance.po i encourage you to
take a look if you are interested in
things like this and also drop me a line
or email twitter whatever works for you
too so you can reach out to me after
this talk if you had any questions feel
free to ask them anytime feel free to
interrupt also you can wait until the
very end will cover all of that
okay moving on the agenda for today's
talk is first we'll try to understand
why was async introduced in the fur in
the beginning why was it useful what it
tried to solve and we'll see whether it
solved it or not then we'll learn some
other concepts in software engineering
like operating system level threads
green threads core routines call cc and
other stuff which can be used to
structure our applications a little
differently and ultimately at the very
end we will just go to the demos showing
you how we could implement async in
different approach the similar approach
that java took on which is way different
than what other languages are doing
so the first thing why async
uh probably you know that since the very
early days of of dotnet development we
always had this need to be able to
execute some code like outside of the
main execution flow we always wanted to
run something in background calculate
something on the side so that's why we
wanted to have this ability to get a
part of this code and just run it
somewhere else in some different way
without actually paying attention to all
those little nasty details how those
things are executed and the first thing
we could use to do that was asynchronous
programming model apm for short so we
had this pattern in c-sharp language
which was based on two methods one of
them named begin something and the
counterpart named and something which
allowed us to execute the calculation on
some other thread context something else
we didn't need to think about how it was
executed but generally it was executed
somewhere the idea was that we just
triggered the operation and then when we
want to utilize the result we have this
end method which either gives us the
result if it's already available or it
blocks until we get the result we also
had to provide this lambda which would
do that like the continuation part so
when the result is done do this thing so
that was the first pattern the second
pattern we could use was eap even base
asynchronous programming model which was
based on the idea that we have this
background worker where we can submit
our jobs to be executed the piece of
code we want to run and it was triggered
executed on this background thingy and
then we had the continuation
used in a way of attaching a callback so
we had a callback which we could attach
to the worker when the
thing to execute to calculate we was
finished we had this callback being
triggered so executed by the by the
platform so that's yet another approach
we had obviously it could be configured
canceled and all that stuff we would
expect from like a decent mechanism to
support the problem with that was with
bose mechanism was that they did not
necessarily allow us to structure the
code in the linear way like both here in
this eap we had to provide this callback
similarly here in this android thingy we
also had those we were we had those
callbacks which were executed when
things were done what we wanted to do
instead we wanted to have a continuation
wrapped as a first class citizen as an
object which we could just carry around
pass from one method to the other which
would encapsulate everything which is to
be done not only the code but also the
parameters all the continuations
security features like user id
impersonation whatever reliability
context whatever else whatever you
imagine right all those had to be
captured in one single object which was
task which we could just carry around
so that's how tap task-based
asynchronous pattern started and we had
this idea that we want to create one
single task which allows us to
encapsulate the logic and then we could
wrap them together with the powerful
continue with method typically the way
we used it was that we just added
continue with and provided yet another
lambda however there were multiple
different parameters like to continue
only if there was an exception or if
there were no exceptions or continue on
different tasks scheduler different
threat pool whatever else multiple
different things if you are interested
more in details how this thing was
constructed etc i encourage you to take
a look at my talk which is internals of
async you can find it on youtube and you
will learn all about that stuff
so this is what pap gave us and also
nice part about tap was it was super
simple to actually make it parallel it
was super straightforward to run it on
multiple threads thanks to peeling what
we had to do is just do dot us parallel
and then bang all the magical functions
we could use with link were executed
like in parallel obviously.net did quite
a lot of scaffolding under the hood also
calculating whether it's worth running
things on multiple threads or whether
they should still go on a single
threaded model whatever else it was
taken care of by the by the platform but
the only thing we had to do was as
parallel and we were all good so that
was the idea the problem with this
approach was that hey we are still
wrapping those things in tasks we still
have those tasks flying around from left
to right and we need to use this
continue with method where we just need
to provide this yet another lambda which
still allows us to go more or less like
linearly but still we have those details
exposed so that's why async and await
came to the game and there was one more
super important thing why async now it
was introduced it was to allow us to
write the code which does not block the
operating system level threat we'll get
to that a little later however before
getting to those details let's see uh a
little like funny remarks about these
inaudible first thing is you can await
anything which is away table it means
it's very similar to the forage loop you
do not need to have any i enumerable eye
whatever rater on top of the collection
you'd like to enumerate over the only
thing you need to do is you need to use
the duct typing if the collection gives
you the move next and the current then
you can do forage over it there is no
interface needed same thing applies to
acing and awaits you need to use the
duct typing to and if you have a type
which is called away table meaning that
it gives you this method called get a
waiter which returns your type which
allows you to check whether the result
is available or or to to continue on the
when the result appears then you can
await on anything meaning that we can
actually await on any integer so let's
go to a very very first simple demo so
what we are doing is we are trying to
await an integer so you can see that
first thingy we do have some code which
slept for like two seconds okay and the
thing which is happening under the hood
is we are just calling a weight two 2000
so we are awaiting 2000 milliseconds
how's that possible the only thing you
need to do is you provide an extension
method and you extend the integer type
to return the away table type so it does
have the method called getawater which
returns you any away table type and
under the hood we are just doing task
delay and returning the same thingy
which task delay would return so when we
call this a weight 2000 what it does
under the hood is it calls integer get
awaiter so it finds the extension method
we we have below it gives the the code
the away table type and we can just wait
for it obviously not suggesting that you
should go and rewrite all your integers
to be available in your code base but
this gives you the idea that hey
anything can be our table and that's the
power of the of the async and away that
you can use it with basically anything
you'd like to
to go with so
that's the thing that's the first thing
we also know that async and now it gives
us this ability to basically write the
code like linearly right we don't need
to think about attaching continuations
we just do await bank we are good that's
what documentation tells us right there
are tons of problems with that and again
i encourage i refer you to yet my
another talk which is called like all
the why async is the worst idea in c
sharp you can find it not youtube
obviously but what we are going to do
for to focus on today is the third part
of the async which is a synchronous code
does not block the operating system
level thread
and this like very simple sentence
actually gives us a lot of time like a
lot of useful information first
we cannot block that's the important
thing but what is even more important
here is we cannot block the operating
system level threat
meaning that with async and await we can
actually block but not on the os fret
and this is what we are going to utilize
under the hood we will see how the
blocking is implemented currently in
c-sharp and then we will see how it
could be implemented in different way so
this is what's up next
and in order to get all of that we need
to go through all those like three big
deals of async and awaiting c-sharps so
the first big deal is async and c-sharp
is implemented as a co-routine compiler
level transformation that's very magical
term which we'll see later on but which
tells us that whenever you write a
method which is marked as async compiler
steps in and rewrites this method into
the
state machine so we'll get that a little
later also similar thing was happening
with viewed keyword compiler was
basically restructuring all your methods
to provide this core routine like
experience the second part is c-sharp
async in c-sharp is implemented as a
service locator for promise
orchestration
meaning that there is a static global
variable named synchronization context
which gives you like the service locator
behavior into how you schedule the
continuations because depending on what
application you run if it's like a
desktop application or if it's like a
web application or if it's a blazer
thingy then your continuations need to
be scheduled differently in desktop
applications they can go on one thread
only because whenever you await on the
user interface the callback needs to be
executed on the same thread which
manages your ui why is that because
otherwise it would have no access to the
ui components buttons labels etc you
would get exception that you are trying
to access the ui from some other thread
however in the web world the only thing
we need to take off is that the
continuation needs to be executed in the
context of the same web request you do
not need to care whether it's exactly
the same thread operating system level
thread but you only want to the only
thing you want to care about is that
it's inquired in the same web request so
you have access to the same like request
headers response headers whatever
similarly in blazer because we are
running in javascript mode then we need
to inject everything into the javascript
like this one single fret pumping
mechanism so this is why the
synchronization context needs to take
care of that and hands up if you ever
heard about synchronization context
there are a couple of hands that's great
for all of you who never heard about
that that's the power of acing and await
that is a service locator which you do
not need to even think about however it
gives you tons of issues if you are
trying to go with like multiple threads
when it's expecting single level threads
so then you have deadlocks and all that
stuff again referring due to some other
sources but generally it can become
nasty and the third part of async in c
sharp is that it has statically bound
promise factories what does it tell us
the task type which we use in c sharp is
known in multiple different languages
like a promise like future depending on
which language you're using you have
different nomenclature right but the
thing is it has the statically bound
promise factories meaning that you have
need to have a factory creating you this
promise and then c-sharp it's statically
bound because you specify the type which
is returned from the method you always
need to specify that it's what it's a
task
but at some point
dotnetplatformer.net team realized that
hey tasks are very heavy they are
garbage collected and all that they have
all the draw like drawbacks of being
like regular gc managed objects so let's
introduce something which is passed via
stack so what happened we had to rewrite
all our functions from task to val to
value task right again that's a nasty
issue with async because hey it's
statically bound so during this talk
we'll address all those three big pieces
of async and 08 and see if we can do
better
so let's move on
the async important thing about async
the mechanism which was introduced in
c-sharp was actually one of the first
mechanisms out there in the enterprise
world it influenced multiple other
languages obviously there were other
like some niche languages which did
support things like that but c-sharp was
the first big one to support those and
it influenced others for instance casco
python javascript typescript etc all of
them implemented async and await
basically in the same way meaning that
there was this scoring transformation
there was some service locator for
orchestrating continuations and there
was some well-known type either like
more directly exposed or hidden via duct
typing whatever else but generally there
was this type which supported the
asynchronous programming however
it does not need to be implemented this
way and when i was preparing this talk
for the first time it was before java 17
was released which was couple years back
and they were working on a different
approach which was called project loom
now this project loom was already
released so what i'm going to show you
is conceptually equivalent to what they
are doing in java so now they have their
own async and await and it will work the
way i'm going to show you today
obviously they are they implemented it
with their own platform yada yada but
generally conceptually indifferent and i
was always saying that
well we don't know which approach is
better when it comes to performance
usability etc we still do not know that
because java released it quite uh quite
recently so we do not have all the data
points however we already see that their
approach may be way more efficient for
for instance now there is there was a
very interesting example released like
literally a couple days ago that the guy
implemented a method or an application
which is able to handle 50 million
concurrent connections on one single box
this is something we cannot do with with
c sharp if you ever heard about c 10k
problem or the challenge to handle 10 10
000 concurrent connections on one single
machine this guy made a big step forward
to see 50 million concurrent connections
so generally
the thing is that this different
approach may be way better in terms of
performance but we'll actually see that
in like five years from now because we
didn't know how it will perform how it
will behave the same we didn't know
about async and await in c sharp now
like a decade later we already know that
c sharp's implementation has tons of
various problems when it comes to
deadlocking when it comes to rewriting
the code colorful functions but we
generally know it's beneficial if we
don't know yet whether java's approach
is better we'll get to know that in
couple of years
moving on in order to understand all
those three big pieces we'll need to go
through some theory so let's dwell into
operating system level threat and what
else we can use to implement
asynchronous programming
so the native thread the first thing we
need to know is whenever we actually
execute something at the very bottom of
the runtime and execution platform there
is there is a thing which is provided by
the operating system which is a native
fret so this is the thread you create
with your win api or p frets or whatever
else is basically a thread so a piece of
machinery which allows you to run a task
something on the which is written or
named by the cpu architecture as a task
so there are two different types of
threads foregrounded background threads
they need to have the stack so memory
allocated for the stack uh in windows
when we are talking about like windows
10 or windows 11 64-bit a typical
application or a typical thread has
three different stacks one for kernel
space one for user space and one for the
windows on windows 64 execution
mechanism and taking into account that
by default user space stack consumes
around one megabyte of memory which may
or may not be committed like from the
from the very beginning but typically it
may be
means that whenever you create a new
fret it allocates one megabyte of memory
so that's why they are telling you hey
do not create threads by hand because if
you try to create 50 millions of them
250 millions concurrent connections you
would have quite a lot of memory
consumed right for doing nothing yet
important thing windows and the same
goes for linux generally anything
running on x86 architecture schedules
threats not processes meaning that the
the threat has its own priority and its
own time slice and it's scheduled by the
operating system
uh on top of that dot net platform gives
you that managed thread so it takes the
native thread and drops it into the
system threading dot thread class which
handles the operating system level
thread gives you quite a couple of
interesting features like you can name a
thread you can attach an id to that so
if you are dumping a memory and then
analyzing your memory dumps then you can
see the the names of the threads so
generally whenever you create a new
thread always give it a name give a name
to it so then when you are trying to
like debug memory dumps you see what
this thread was supposed to be doing and
not only what it's doing
uh generally it pre-commits the stack
when a thread is created meaning that
whenever you create a new thread in dot
net it does allocate the memory for you
and also if you have an unaccounted
exception on a thread it kills your
application so generally whenever you
create a thread always do try catch
catch everything
so your application doesn't die give it
a name and then let it go so this is
what we have at the very at the very
bottom
now the concept of operating system
level threat is very useful for us
because well everything in user space
needs to use some kind of threading
machinery however nothing stops us from
implementing threads in like the user
space
so what we do is we can create our own
threads running entirely in net entirely
in c-sharp and not being run and managed
by the operating system level threat and
those are called green threads the name
green actually comes from java again
because java started with their own
implementation on the frets and it was
developed by the green team in sun
microsystems so that's why they called
them green threads and their names
stayed
around for a little longer so that's why
we are calling them green threads the
thing about green threads is they are
not scheduled by the os
just like a couple
slides back i told you that windows
schedule frets this is different here
it's not with windows which schedules
frets but it's there a runtime platform
so it would be net jvm javascript v8
engine whatever you you name and now the
important thing about that is you need
to run those threads on top of something
so now you have the idea of mapping your
green threads to operating system level
threads so you can go with multiple
different mappings you can go with
direct mapping one to one so one green
thread is one os fret or you could go
with multiple frets going to a single os
fret or any way you wish so your threads
can migrate can carry their their state
in between different os threats etc so
generally we can re-implement anything
the important part is we need to take
care of everything when we are doing
that so that's why most platforms do not
want to do that but nothing stops us
from doing so the advantages are first
if we are taking care of creating those
threats this can be way faster because
we do not need to switch to the kernel
thread and the user space kernel space
user space back and forth right we can
do all the scheduling directly in the
user space which can be faster so
depending on the which implementation
you use you may actually see some
performance gains with green threads
however there are also issues with that
because we are just running those green
threads on top of native threads you
cannot use actually multiple processors
depending on which scheme you have if
you are mapping like n threads to a
single os fret then at some point in
time only one green thread can be
executed right because you're mapping to
one os fret you cannot get true
parallelism with this approach with this
mapping you need to go with something
slightly more clever but generally the
the the outcome is you cannot get the
full parallels move this way also when
it comes to the i o operations we have
this drawback that whenever we have n
threads which needs to be executed by
your runtime when a thread gets blocked
for instance because you did file readal
text and you are waiting for the data to
arrive then effectively all those end
threads are being blocked why because
your operating system level threat is
suspended waiting for the data so
whenever you go with this approach you
always need to go with asynchronous
operations all the way down otherwise
you have issues and you you cannot get
the performance but that's the idea
there are obviously different variations
of this concept depending on the
language like erlang uses green
processors because they do not share the
memory it's generally julia uses
something different python uses tasks
generally it's the same concept but
there are details in implementation
moving on so we have operating system
level frets on top of them we could
build green frets what would the green
threads give us the idea is that we can
assign work to different green threads
and whenever we want to await something
we can switch to a different green
thread right and operating system does
not need to know about that but we could
take a different approach we can go with
thing called core routines
instead of having a method which allows
us just to be executed like once from
the very beginning to the very end when
there is the return keyword what we can
do instead is we can come up with a
method which can be suspended and
resumed and the method which can return
a value multiple times and this is the
code co routine so generally a single
routine is basically a very specific
case of corrupting which returns just
once
meaning that when we have a core routine
a core routine can decide when it wants
to return a value and the question is
how can that be useful for us
and the answer is what we do have in
c-sharp is the yield keyword and this is
basically a core routine what we do have
is we have a for loop counting from zero
to whatever and we do want to return
multiple values so we do yield return it
returns multiple values as you can see
whenever you call yield return this
method is suspended you can take the
value use it and then when someone wants
to get another value it resumes the
method and waits for another value now
the question is how is that implemented
under the hood and couple slides back i
told you that compiler uses core routine
transformation and this is exactly the
place where the core routine
transformation happens so when we have a
method like from the slide which we've
seen which is just four lubely turning
value this is what compiler creates for
you under the hood it gets the creates
the class which has a method get counter
returning you i enumerator and what it
does next is it creates a very nasty
class generated by the compiler which
holds things like state current value
and all that stuff and provides a method
which is called move next which does all
the heavy lifting so whenever you
call this method
if you see how the compiler generates
the code for you like the color of this
method calls getcounter and gets the
ienumerator class ienumerator instance
and then repeatedly calls move next
method on top of that and this move next
method it knows where it is and it
reworks this whole forage loop the for
loop here it reworks all the exception
handling all the stuff and just knows
where to carry on from after you get the
value so you call move next it
calculates the next value returns this
value which you can later get using the
using the current property and this is
how you operate you get the innumerator
from here you call move next it tells
you hey i do have another value returns
you true then you go to current get the
value then you call move next again and
so on this is what is happening with the
yield keyword and interestingly enough
the same thingy is happening with async
and await but we will get to that in a
sec so drawbacks of this idea of this
approach is they introduce the so-called
function coloring whenever we have this
yield return we cannot just go with
method returning integer right we need
to return i enumerator of integer right
or i am numerable of integer we cannot
go with just a single value we always
need to go with the collection so this
is called function coloring we have
colorless functions which can return
anything and we have colored functions
which can return anything wrapped inside
the collection inside the i enumerable
so the problem with that is
those methods can not necessarily be
used in like void contexts right you
cannot await your method in a
constructor right because if you do
await it then you would need to call
await on the method however then you
would need to return a task from the
constructor but you cannot return a task
from the constructor because you're just
returning the instance so there's one
problem the other problem is well your
async methods they generally cannot
return void i mean technically it's
possible but gives you so many problems
that better not do that but generally
this is something we can't do in in all
the contexts we would like to do
also when it comes to exception handling
they change a lot they also increase the
memory allocation because we need to
create the intermediate collections etc
generally multiple problems even though
this gives us quite a lot of benefits
now how does it work with async if we
take a method like this
and we have console.writeline await
writeline await yada yada what the
compiler does under the hood is first it
creates you this our async method so we
start with our async method here and we
have a series of print lines and and the
weights so it gives you this method
which looks very
like straightforward right but what it
does under the hood it utilizes again
some compiler generated type which does
all the heavy lifting again we have the
move next method which handles all the
different states which does the switch
case which breaks which jumps around you
can even go to here so generally an sd
code and it awaits all the stuff returns
you all these things so this is the code
which is generated 130 lines for this
single method so this is the core
routine transformation
done for you by the shop compiler the
important thing is that this c-sharp
compiler transformation is like
transparent for the net platform meaning
that's the advantage of async your dot
net platform does not need to know
anything about asynchronous code because
compiler does the heavy lifting so this
is why it's way simpler to implement
because you can just do it in the
compiler you don't need to have any
runtime support nor the operating system
support
okay so that's yet another approach now
when it comes to a different thing we
could do is we can go with a thing which
is called continuation passing style
instead of writing a method which gives
us a value we can write a method which
gives the value to the continuation and
calls the continuation sounds tricky but
generally is rather straightforward
let's see this is the action let's say
that we would like to calculate a
fibonacci number so the regular
implementation would be hey give me a
fibonacci of n so n fibonacci number
right what we do is some black magic
with switch case and then returning the
fibonacci but the ultimately what we do
is we just return the value okay this is
what we do we return the value so
whenever we want to print this value
what we do is we calculate we call the
fibonacci method here and then this
value which is being returned is
actually passed to this point
okay because we get the value and then
pass it through with cps what we do is
we ask the method to continue for us so
that's the difference this method knows
now not only gets the parameter hey
which fibonacci would like to calculate
but also what would you like to do next
so this is the cps continuation passing
style and the difference is we call the
fibonacci passing it the parameter we
want the 10th fibonacci number and we
also ask the method hey when you are
done
do not get back to me do not give me the
result what you should do instead is
just call this code code is lambda so
this is the cps and you can obviously
see this approach with the task wrapper
right task continue with when you are
done don't give me the result by go with
this continuation what does this give us
well
this approach if we bend our minds a
little more this allows us to implement
a thing which is called co-cc call with
current continuation so what this allows
us is we can actually turn the things
inside out to implement any construction
instruction controls we would like to
have for instance to implement like the
the break return or whatever else and
now how would the continue go with cc
call with current continuation look like
in c sharp
so let's say that we have a regular
method which accepts the continuation
okay and what we do in this foo method
is we first call this continuation
passing it number two or value two and
then we return free and ultimately we
print the value returned by the function
so this is a regular c sharp so this
returns free right like the continuation
here which is passed here is basically
the empty lambda so it doesn't matter
okay but now if we had call with cc in
c-sharp what we would do is we could
call cc sorry for that we could call cc
foo this way
so then the compiler what it would do or
the runtime what it would do is it would
take everything following the full
execution so everything following the
full execution is probably a thing like
this one
so then this mingy is ultimately wrapped
into a lambda continuation which is then
passed as this bar
okay so now when fu
calls the bar continuation so when we
call bar with number two what happens
next is the foo is being terminated and
we continue with the continuation and
the continuation is this thingy so the
console.writeline so then it prints two
so this is the pattern which we can take
and this is exactly like async and await
is yet another way of using this pattern
even in a very narrow context we just
want to await the the thingy and then
continue with it but this is what the
compiler does for us
so this is when it comes to cps green
threads and all that stuff
and now to get it a little more usable
for us what we need to use is there is a
thingy there is a question i believe
right
uh
that's a made-up syntax because c sharp
does not support
call with current continuation this is
how it could look like in c sharp how
you would call with parameters probably
parenthesis and etc
cool uh moving on then
so fibers we already covered operating
system level threads we covered green
threads now windows provides you a thing
which is called a fiber that's a
green level thread implemented by the
win api
the idea with fiber is that basically
it's a thread which is cooperatively
multitasked meaning that a thread asks
to be rescheduled
so similarly to what we have with
coroutines you need to have async you
have to have an await keyword or yield
return keyword to indicate where you
want to switch the context so this is
the cooperative multitasking but it's
implemented by the win api
so the problem of this approach is that
gives you a significant memory usage
because it's implemented in the windows
api so in the kernel mode so it cannot
use um like it doesn't give you all the
performance benefits however
it also have this drawback off because
it's a green level thread when you have
multiple fibers you need to use the
asynchronous programming model to do at
the i o otherwise you block all the
fibers and you you cannot get the
performance and you cannot use all the
things for locking etc but generally
this allows us to implement the green
thread approach like super simple
because we have it already exposed so
what do we need to do imagine that we
now want to implement async
knowing all the things about green level
threats about the continuation passing
style about the core routines we want to
use fibers of the green level threads to
implement async how do we need to do
that technically we need to call a
couple of win api methods to convert a
threat to fiber and then we can use
switch to fiber to switch between
threads
how do we do that to do async this is
the part next part of this talk so let's
see
what we are going to do
let's close this one let's start with
the regular ac example and see what we
are doing
so
uh let's start this up first the
important thing about async as i
mentioned is that we cannot block the
operating system level threat that's the
crucial point of asynchronous
programming if at any point of time we
block the os fret then there is no using
ac at all what we are doing is we will
have a demo uh an example code which
will use multiple times throughout the
demo to show you what we are tweaking
with so first thing we are doing is we
want to execute two tasks like in
parallel concurrently side by side first
of them is run internal and then we have
some interjected side job they don't do
anything special run internal is just a
calling run internal nested which sleeps
for two seconds awaits the sleep returns
some data yada yada nothing special okay
important part is it waits it takes some
time for it to finish because it needs
to block on something
and then we are just awaiting this okay
so we are sleeping for two seconds
that's the important part the second
important part is we are running a side
job so in the time when we are sleeping
we would like this side job to be
executed and this side job does nothing
is just print okay
so what we want to see in all the
examples is we want to have this output
that we are running that there's some
nesting inside this regular job and then
somewhere in between we have our side
job interjected okay
you can see that we are effectively
sleeping for two seconds so this side
job is executed in is like two seconds
which we can use to do anything and then
the continuation finishes okay so that's
the idea
so this is the regular
regular async and the weight code you
would be implementing without the
correcting transformation etc now how
can we do exactly the same with yield
keyword
the important thing is that youth
keyword which was their like couple
years back before
uh before async and await allows us to
exact to do exactly the same so now we
are going to reimplement async and await
with a reviewed keyword so first thing
we'll need to do is we'll need to have
some bookkeeping which is done for you
by the dotnet platform so whenever you
do ac you use async and await when you
await something there is this
continuation which is pushed on the
synchronization context which is
basically put into some queue and then
the thread observes the queue if there
is a new message in the queue meaning
that hey you need to do some more work
it takes the message from the queue does
the work and carry on okay so that's the
idea we need to re-implement this part
so what we have is we have dictionaries
of all the jobs we'd like to be doing
some semaphore for synchronizing on top
of the queue and then we also have the
enumerator
so this is a kind of the regular
enumerator you have in c sharp but with
flag whether there is some work more to
be done and the idea is we'll stack
those enumerators on top of the other so
whenever you do want to
now you we want to bend our minds and
instead of doing a weight on a method we
want to do yield return on a method
and the thing is that the method which
we are yield returning it can also await
inside so it can also do yield return so
when we are doing yield returns we need
to return collections right so before
continuing with returning the external
collection we need to return the
internal connection which a collection
which was there so when we are doing
guild return we need to understand there
was this stack of enumerators built on
top of each other and this is why we
have the
the the enumerator with flag to
basically build this stack of thingies
what we do is we have the move next
method in this enumerator which
basically checks hey if i was already
done then i'm done otherwise i get the
enumerator which was there and i call
move next in it if we've seen this move
next method with the for loop for
instance we are basically calculating
next integer right
if there is nothing which we calculated
then we try like unstacking the thing we
check whether we were stacked enumerator
and we remove it from the top of the
stack or we can obviously push something
more on the stack
we'll see that in how we are going to
implement the run internal so this is
the same thing in which we had with
async and awaits so now we are what we
are doing is we are calling the run
internal nested we are getting its
enumerator and marking it hey you go
ahead do your work and then instead of
doing a wait we can do yield return okay
and this thing there's this run internal
nested is yet another thingy which
returns us the i enumerable something
instead of task and again when we are we
want to wait for it we just do yield
return and because we are mixing this
with tasks around then we have some
magic weight which is not important the
general idea is instead of using a
weight we do the yield return
so the way we do it is we have a run
method so the main thread which has
those cues of the things to be executed
okay
so what we do is we loop through this
queue we get the thingy from this queue
and while there is something to be done
we just get it and call the move next
method from the enumerator and there if
there is something new to be scheduled
new continuation then this new
continuation is pushed into this queue
again so this is how we implement it and
if we are all done then we just break
nothing nothing important here so the
important or the interesting part about
that let me just check yeah this
compiled correctly you can see that hey
with this approach we can also get
exactly the same thingy so we are now
running with generators instead of the
acing and await we can get the sorry we
can get this side job being interjected
somewhere in between and we can get this
two seconds delay and this is actually
something people were implementing
before async and await was introduced to
the c-sharp you can go look over stack
overflow and you'll find people asking
how do i use yield to implement async
and await and they were doing that so
this is something you can implement by
hand
and this is the way it's implemented
under the hood like all this queueing
all this scheduling is done for you
and now we enter a slightly different
world because the problem with those
score routines is you can see it
actually even clearer here that hey you
wanted to return something from this run
internal and it needs to be i enumerable
again it cannot be just the integer
right it needs to be the enumerator you
need to go with all these bookkeeping
handling transformations yada yada i
want to have an async where i can do
return i can return anything and i don't
need to care about those that stuff how
do i do that and this is how it comes
so now what we are going to do is we are
going to use fibers
so
to the recap we have this operating
system level fret which is basically a
single thread provided to us by the
operating system and on top of that we
built green level threats we built
fibers each fiber is basically one async
and a weight context which will execute
so what we are doing is
we have again some bookkeeping for doing
the queuing and all that stuff the same
way field as as before and now what we
are doing is we submit two jobs to the
to the uh to the execution logic the
first job is the regular run internal
you can see is just a void method it
does run internal nested which gets the
task.delay
then instead of calling await on this
delay instead of calling a delay.weight
what we do is we do the magic weight and
this is the method we all wanted to have
this is the method which just stops the
method waits for the result but allows
everything else to carry on
how is this implemented we'll have three
fibers in this application first fiber
so the first green thread is the green
thread which is running this pumping
inside the queue so we get the message
from the queue indicating hey there is
some work to be done
and what we do next is we just switch to
this fret so we do the context switch to
the other fiber we tell the operating
system hey me i'm fiber numbered zero
i'm done you can carry on with executing
this other fiber okay so at this point
the fiber number zero is basically
stopped here
like
post entirely and then fiber number one
is being executed it goes on and on
until it calls magic.weight and in
magic.weight what we do
is we basically schedule a continuation
to schedule fibers again but we more
importantly we ask the operating system
hey i'm done you can go to fiber zero so
there is this fiber zero which goes
through the queue gets the messages and
then tells the os hey go to fiber one to
do this method when this
method
on fiber one wants to wait wants to
await for something it tells the us hey
i'm done go to fiber zero okay and then
there is continuation on this task which
when it's done so when we are weight
done waiting for the delay or whatever
else we tell we add this fiber to the
queue indicating that hey this fiber is
ready to be carried on again so then
fiber number zero will pick it up from
the queue and tell the us claim i'm done
go to fiber one and on fiber two what we
do is on fiber two we just submit the
side job okay so this is the important
thing that we just submit the side job
which is here okay and now to see this
in output you can see that hey we do
have this running as expected
so we have again sleeping for two
seconds okay
and we have the side job being
interjected somewhere in between
so this is what we can do with fibers
now how do we implement that the part of
the queuing here you already know there
were some cues with keyword the other
part which we need to have is we need to
have basically some i use c plus plus
cli to basically call the win api
methods right so the only thing we need
to do is we need to be able to
call the switch to fiber from the win
api delete fiber and there is convert
thread to fiber and that's all if you
have this you can actually go with the
implementation of the async and await on
top of green level threads and this is
exactly what java project loom does so
instead of using this choruiting
transformations we just go with green
threads on top of the os frets
so the advantages of this well some of
them are actually
strikingly clear there is no more task
you can just return void you don't need
to rewrite all your synchronous code to
async to have acing all the way down
continue configure a weight all the way
up all the stuff the only thing you need
to do is you just do the delay dot magic
weight
that's it
but that's not beyond the not the end of
the story you remember this slide when i
was pointing out three most important
parts of async and away first was
coroutine transformation okay so this is
covered we got that covered the other
part was service locator okay service
locator for orchestrating the
continuations what we are going to do
now is we are going to change the
service
locator thingy and let me just tweak the
code because it's quite a lot of code
changes now so let's run it and now what
we are going to do is
we would like to use monad like approach
for those of you who were sleeping for
the last decade and not reading yet
another post explaining what the monad
is
this is not a moment just telling you
what we are going to do instead if we
are just wrapping this thing in a monad
like structure so don't like play tricks
on that it's not a moment however what
is important is we would like to have an
execution environment and we would like
to have two different builders for two
different monarchs so basically a monard
is a box with something inside and this
box takes care of how to deal with that
thing inside so we'll have two different
boxes one of them being id builder like
id box which is identity and the other
box is a synchronous box and now comes
the thing
instead of doing the uh the any thing
with returning values directly now we
want to do actually and take a step back
and put everything into those boxes
so whenever we are dealing with the
values we are not doing them like
linearly with a weight or like linear
like code but we are more going with uh
with an approach of like continue with
on a task okay so we have this box and
instead of using continue wave we use
the map function we name him we name it
map so we have a value so we have a
something which is away table or sleep
label here and it's inside this box and
then when it's done sleeping we have
continue with so it does something with
the value okay so we wrap this thingy
here now the important thing is we have
two different builders for that so we
run this application first with the
asynchronous builder using async box and
when we run it we get the expected
output right so we have the sleeping for
two seconds in between and we also have
this side job being introdu introduced
interjected somewhere okay
however now the thing is we can replace
this box because we are using the
factory which is not uh like located by
a service locator it is provided we can
just change it to something like this so
we pass it as a parameter to the
execution context we are dealing with
and if we now change the asynchronous
builder to the synchronous one you can
see that the side job was introduced at
the very end because it was waiting for
the previous part to finish meaning that
just by changing this thingy here
at the top of the application like in
your dependency injection container or
whatever you can control how the async
asynchronicity is being executed you can
control all the threading anything
around you do not need to touch the code
the business logic which is there okay
so this is great that's the second thing
but the third thing which we want to fix
here which we really don't like is hey
we took the step back and now we are
wrapping everything inside this box okay
that's terrible let's get rid of that
and the last part which we are going to
do is we address this third cornerstone
of the async programming which was that
statically bound promise factories so
now instead of using those boxes like
directly what we are going to do is we
are going to use them in some more
dynamic way thanks to again something
similar to higher kind of type
so what we are going to do is a higher
kind of type
is a generic method which is
being generic not on the input type but
the output type like you have i
enumerable of t that's a regular generic
but you could have t of integer that's a
higher kind of type meaning that the
kind of the the generic part is outside
something which c sharp does not provide
for you directly you can emulate the
dead with with various transformations
again but we are going this approach so
now what we are going to do is
we are going to have um this run
internal method run internal nested
again they are like regular methods no
tasks around
no boxes no continue with no map the
only thing which it does is it gets this
type parameter t like generic parameter
and this generic parameter is of some
builder yada yada just to get the call
compiled and then you see that we are
calling task delay like in this way
delay of t
we don't care what this t was okay but
we are just just passing it through
and again the idea is if we do it this
way we can control it from the very top
so
see you can we can again get the two
second sleep as needed we can get the
side job interjected in between but just
by changing this one little thingy like
this one parameter generic parameter
from asynchronous box to synchronous box
what we get now is we get that the side
job is executed synchronously at the
very end so this is what we can do now
and you can see that we by doing all
those different transformations we ended
up with code which is colorless there is
no task around here no task no value
task if microsoft introduces yet another
magicking task you don't care you don't
need to rewrite your code base anymore
you can control whether it's synchronous
or not you can change the synchronous
mechanism you can change the number of
threads fretboos whatever you wish
without touching your business code you
control the synchronous parts
directly in a place where they are
executed because nothing stops you from
calling this method once with id builder
and the other time with asynchronous
builder so you can change it in runtime
dynamically the way you wish
important thing is because it's a
generic parameter and this builder
thingy
is uh
sorry this uh those monarchs can be
introduced by the compiler meaning that
if you do have those builders you could
go with structures meaning that your
compiler would understand that those
things can be heavily optimized there
would be no need for you to introduce
value task anymore or anything like this
because compiler would just get rid of
the allocations for you and that's it so
you don't need to change your business
code anymore you don't need to do any
code rewriting into async and await
async all the way all the way up
configure await false all the way down
or whatever way it was you don't need to
change your methods you don't need to
deal with synchronization context and
deadlocks nothing like this the only
thing you do is you can just have it
here with the green level threads and
this is what project bloom does
obviously your compiler could hide those
t parameters from you
and that's done
so
being all of that set we can wrap up
this talk so we can see that core
routines even though they give us this
very nice experience of acing and await
they generally
give or bring quite a lot of overhead
which we can get rid of by using
completely different approach we don't
need to use global state anymore we
don't need to use colorful functions we
don't need to pass tasks around from
here and there we could go with
something completely different based on
green level threads or whatever and it
would work exactly the same way and
could be as java suggests way more
performance
being all of that said it's time for q a
so this qr code points you to the slide
deck uh or actually to my blog to the
blog with the slides and couple more
materials and at the very end of this
slide deck there are more references for
you like books blog links etc etc feel
free to take a look at them
and that's it if do you if you have any
questions now it's a perfect time to ask
them
there is one yes
okay so the question is why isn't this
what we did here why isn't that
implemented in the operating system in
the very first place and that's actually
a very good play a very good question on
one hand we do not want to have these
things in the os itself because then
well dotnet wants to support multiple
platforms now so having that implemented
in windows only would need to mean that
we need to implement this in linux by
ourselves or whatever or need to have
exactly the same implementation in linux
but the other
other thing is that those things were
not implemented in this way like why
they were not implemented in the dotnet
runtime why they were implemented in the
c-sharp compiler the answer is because
it's a choice to be made basically it's
a decision to be made so dotnet platform
decided that they do not want to mess
with the dotnet runtime to support all
of that they wanted to mess with the
c-sharp compiler that's why they
implemented it in this way they also
didn't want to mess with the operating
system to add all those stuff
java took a different route they decided
to change all the platform under the
hood so all languages can benefit from
there you do not have async and await in
vb.net right because it's not
implemented in the compiler but if you
do have multiple languages running on
java then in theory any of them can use
all the benefits here now when it comes
to the american memory consumption etc
generally if you are implementing things
in the operating system then you need to
deal with the
with the kernel switch context switch to
the kernel mode which is always heavy
always very very expensive and generally
you don't want to do not want to to do
that and you cannot get rid of that
because of security and all the other
implement
implications so generally while it is
beneficial if you have those things
provided for you it's actually very
heavy for the os itself or the dependent
platforms to implement them and that's
why you might want to consider
implementing them by yourself
any other questions yep
okay so the question is i did convert
the thread to fiber and the question is
how does it integrate with other things
which can be around like dispatch
context in that wpf
web requests etc etc the answer is
microsoft or actually the dotnet
platform they did consider using fibers
at some point they were supporting that
in sql server and it's some clr version
but at some point that explicitly drop
that support because fibers do not give
you like make your
uh multi-threading code a little tricky
because all your synchronization
primitives like mutexes semaphores
they are always tied to the thread
so now if you have two green frets
running on top of one os thread then in
one green fret takes a lock then the
other green thread has this lock
acquired as well so that's why they
wanted to drop it because support in
multiple platforms in p invoke context
etc was tricky and they explicitly
banned it not that they are not
supporting fibers they are explicitly
unsupporting them
okay
so how does it integrate with wpf etc
this code does not because it's just a
proof of concept you could go with the
places when i'm doing those boxes like
id builder async builder you could
introduce all your logic there it could
be integrated this is why it took java
so long to implement this because they
had to take care of all those things but
the other question is okay i mentioned
that synchronization primitives are
broken with green threads let's say
but is it any different we're facing in
a weight and the answer is it is not
if you do take a lock in your
asynchronous method then it is not
migrating to the other thread you may be
running your continuation on if you do
use async and await you need to forget
about all the regular synchronization
primitives so the thing is microsoft
didn't want to
drop those primitives by moving to
fibers but they effectively dropped them
the same way by moving to async and
await and now there is no code which is
not async enabled in c sharp right there
was this very long transition period
like five years when we were rewriting
all the methods from regular to task
async await yada yada now everything is
async and the weight so you cannot use
your lock primitives anymore even if you
try using lock construct in like async
method it may yell that you cannot await
inside the lock right because it won't
migrate to the other thingy so those are
exactly the same things the same issues
for which microsoft didn't want to go
with fibers but effectively went with
them when introducing async and await so
to sum up
this gives you a lot of troubles when it
goes to going with green threads but you
have those issues the same with facing
an l8 and i refer you to my other other
targeting biggest c-sharp mistake you
can find it on youtube explaining all
those issues but generally you do not
have any more troubles per my
understanding there could be so much
cases obviously but generally this is
equivalent when it comes to how many
troubles you get and uh if you can
integrate this with wpf dispatcher or
whatever else the answer is yes you just
need to write a little more or sometimes
way more code doing the whole the job
under the hood but it was done anyway
for racing and await if you start
compiling async and await you will see
tons of different synchronization
contexts for wpf for blazer for old
asp.net for newasp.net you'll find that
code being written anyway is just we
would need to write this code
having different mechanism in mind
that's it the code needs to be written
anyway
any other questions
okay i don't see any any of them if you
had any other questions feel free to ask
them after the presentation couple of
references for you you can find them in
the slide deck and because we are out of
time being all of that said i think it's
time to call it a day thank you for
attending this talk hope you liked it
hope you enjoyed thank you
you